yay hello welcome to this broadcast no
you're not late today shaven again yeah
hello to all of you in the chat there's
a question right away can you recommend
a book or DVD about the Kings Indian
Makka gone off especially the exchange
hmm no there is a book come by and
what's what's his name grievous I think
beating the fianchetto defenses also but
it's rather outdated so it's not not
that that great i have i think um it has
the exchange but it's not such an
exciting line anyway the exchange
variation i played it a bit it's not not
that brilliant yeah okay so um answer
that question and again hello to all of
you I'm going to play a couple of
five-minute games and I haven't played a
game today so will be yeah but the
tricky hope I am warming up warming up
quickly Mary adjust screen a little bit
okay playing Maradona here this is the
all and Islands okay and there is no
reputation of the Scandinavian it's a
question when will I produce a video on
the rillo pass Maya 45 repertoire that
will be a while I guess I have to
complete the Italian game first
what's the main theoretical I of the
Queen D aids can you name it I don't
know I'm sorry guys my knowledge of the
Scandinavian is like about zero so I
went for this old Indian set up here and
Dwight is going for a double fianchetto
very solid set up here for white maybe I
should have played before hmm
interesting yeah well a six was kind of
a wedding yeah I wonder to be Freud's a
movie or is that bad let's see no I'm
about the book project and I'm doing
something but i'll be doing something
but i'm not entirely sure it's very
largely going to be for white yeah it
will be some kind of wide repertoire and
it's not clear if it would be a book at
all it also might be something um that
will be released as web content not
quite sure I'm going to do something but
it's not um not yet clear yes I also
considered to do something on the
Sicilian tomorrow off but I wonder if
maybe a white book is interesting also
um yeah there are some areas own of wide
repertoire that are not really done so
much in opening theory and I'm thinking
about a couple of them something with D
for something with Knight f3 maybe also
an idea three base repertoire for
example could be interesting
so and we have an interesting position
here I've got this porn on your phone
that's good gives me some space now it
won't be a chessbase DVD I'm definitely
not I would only release something like
that on my own account the Italian game
video whom shown it will add bond beam
won't be very long I mean I'm I'm
honored of working on on this a little
bit seeing what I recommend I'm kind of
curious what my opponent is doing here
he's simply not moving at all I mean I
like my position but why is he not
moving it's difficult for white if he
goes before then the c-4 porn is
weakened
yeah I'm going rukan can also t I've
ever taken 94 gets interesting hmm yeah
hmm yeah night to d4 mmm okay so maybe
just retake with the pawn so um so there
is a question about my name's Oh booga
book if I have a recommendation against
193 and to c4 and yeah it's difficult to
get a new mobo go down it's not an
Universal when you've Universal weapon
however there is an interesting thing
that you can try now they are 39 f6c for
we go to 96 it's an interesting idea if
white goes d for you go e 6 and then you
very likely transpose to something that
could come out of the repertoire the the
namazu ending Zurich Zurich variation
for example is something that can easily
happen um there are some interesting
ideas also you can go if I the white is
not going d4 it's not not a bad idea at
all okay um I'm not quite sure what I
should do here yeah maybe just 95 not
quite clear yeah it's going to take it i
think i'm just going to claim that i'm
in good shape with the bishop pair even
though this isn't entirely clear so what
am I doing here I'm covering this stuff
i was wondering if i can go age for g4
and then sacrifice a piece m97 he will
take these six unfortunately that was
something that i also had planned okay
let's do it like this Bishop to e5 and
Knight to g5 maybe
yeah that knight c6 idea against Knight
f3 c4 is interesting nobody plays that
but I don't know why I don't think it
has any drawback I've played it in
tournament shares already won or I think
two times with good results so what
happens here um 95 or I don't know
veggie 549 f3 or something I've got some
pieces there okay so he allows me to do
that let's go ahead let's get going I
mean he doesn't have to take but Knight
takes h4 is something that he has to
take into account ok now the rook hangs
I can take now he has no good way to
recapture yeah I'm winning this game
funny um yeah shout out to Christophe
not me but yours in yours brother hey
okay playing drain you sooner berg
Henson or sooner Berenson sooner Berg
Hanson sounds kind of wrong wow it's
really high rated at the moment he's
always always some highly ranked at five
minute but 25 40 4 to 5 45 is really
high so um we get some semi sloth
Kenneth position age 6 okay
I could have taken my probably that it's
not really doing that much either so um
this line is considered to be very solid
for black is going light Bishop be 797
and quick c5 if possible I have played
this in turn the chest I'd have went a 4
in that game not sure if this is right
but I'm going to play it again
trying to provoke some a sick smooth a
six I go 92
now he's taking some time it looks very
normal though a six maybe rook c8 okay
one day six okay going to be six hmm so
c5 probably coming but it's not so easy
to play I mean b5 is this kind of
weakish and okay I'm going to take him
trade and now going to take on c5 or not
mmm I won them see how I move that no
not really and he cannot take so i can
cancel first taking it looks wrong yeah
he has to play this smooth and now it
says something that I can do it if I
take and wait if he if it takes with the
piece i have before maybe for quincy
eight what was the highest-rated
opponent eyes to see with the cilia
counterpart kawana m Nakamura I guess
I'm highest-rated opponent over the
board awesome at the time of playing
probably Europe you reek reverse co at
the time to six seventy or something
which I drew it was a good good game who
draw so um what about this if I take on
f6 here he has to take with not quite
sure
hmm that's interesting before is
possible for Quincy eight i wonder if
Bishop have six first and some is
helping me
it's also the simple move Queen to be 3
i'm not sure about okay i'm going before
and I've never played grief shock on the
SSC I think so here not sure I don't
think that's much anything better than
taking and then Bishop b5 now I have not
seen pawn sacrifice and from what I read
I don't know they changed some of the
some of the things that happened in the
match and I find this kind of kind of
wrong Bishop g3 g4 95 years you cannot
take on d 2 so night c4 or maybe rupee
one yeah yeah someone says um that John
the Ptolemy's recently in a video did
the Ehlo test that ello meter or
something like that yeah it's funny I
think I have yeah there's nothing to
dramatize and the match it was dramatic
as it was so you don't need to change
something that already was interesting
so can i play blindfold chess yes I
don't do it but of course yeah the you
know meters i was thinking about it but
i don't i didn't want to just blindly
copy something that someone else did
wanted to check this out first i saw
that he did it but did not yet think
about it if it is something that i would
would want to do Knight g4 him I'm just
back I guess once night takes g4 an idea
you can also play Bishop deform
one night be three here and I'd be three
should be three might be possible hmm ok
I'm doing here yeah the Black Knights
tango isn't played often but it's not
that bad it is fairly ok I've played it
quite a bit in the past and I cannot
really say that there's something
particularly wrong with it
so let's go here yeah the iqp is not
nice but it's not really a big issue i
think and i can also take my king
position is more of a problem
yeah I hope I get to the king in the
center 30 seconds that's not good that's
the biggest issue actually not the
position i believe okay that's no good
yeah mm-hmm let's bad King c3m I didn't
play that well I think it's still a draw
but you would probably--he win on time
and
that position is a draw i think the
fortress but he's so much had on the
clock and maybe he can somehow i would
maneuver me hear some kind of Zeus one
that's actually not a bad spot for the
bishop yeah it's a draw but not with
this time no now okay i was just too
slow so and if sooner berg hands and
played a tournament with last bow hands
eric hansen and the members of the boy
band Hanson who would win probably the
boy band if they play their annoying mmm
bop music terrible terrible yeah yeah
there's also cast in hanson and probably
there's someone called austin and a
couple of handles and that's a difficult
one actually i think between sunni Burke
Hanson last points Eric Hanson there is
not a big difference in raiding hmm hard
to say really you also shouldn't forget
Kurt Hansen he also was very strong yeah
now it was mentioned um I really don't
know who would win that I think it's a
close call it's very close call so I'm
playing morrow Angus and Gus Hansen yeah
gasps would probably be very cool about
it so we have the Scotch opening I've
played this guy in some games recently I
don't think we had two scotch on the
board
night f5 here hmm I think I go gt6
there's a question do I think that I
have a chance against Eric Hanson in
bullet no simple co simple answer is no
he's just too good I think with I think
whether if I would really practice very
very hard it could maybe get some kind
of match out of it so that he's not
winning like all games but it's um it's
really something that I'm wow really
okay thank you very much I'll take the
structure so maybe you should PM very
weird and under normal circumstances I'm
losing against Eric Hanson bullet like I
don't know with what hmm yeah how many
points would I get one out of ten maybe
something like that definitely not not
not more not much more Knight to f3 yeah
interesting I was thinking about this I
think I'm going to if I could take
taking is not as bad as it looks maybe
but night to c5 is also interesting his
Queen really has very little squares
well okay
where are you going with your queen mr.
morrow anguish I'm going to win stuff
here GF night c4 there was a bad game
when in d2 and so let's get going from
the next game and if short is taller
than thailand tireless shorter than
short who is schlechter lynch left up
yeah that's a that's a funny funny thing
yeah Carl schlechter the World
Championship challenger in the match
against laska in the nineteen when was
that to any snow earlier right yeah
10-15 something yeah schlechter is
actually the German name for worse as
all of its a pretty bad name for a chess
player I am pretty bad name to a chess
player what I would say however there
are worse names for chess players in in
in German and Germany here not too far
away from from my place there's a player
with the last name of pizza that's a
funny name a question what do I think
about Nakamura here I'd she says it
seems to me that he improved a lot
during the last year or two yes i agree
i think he matured really if i'm
pronouncing that somewhat correctly it's
um it's clearly am it's clear and
obvious that he's now a much more
well-rounded player then he was a couple
of years ago yeah we see all kinds of
games not just like heavy tactics or
whatever it's um it's a good a good mix
schlechter was last guy was 1910 yeah
nakamura really i think you're really
improved I mean and it's not something
that is just a matter of rating points I
mean like like being complete as a
player what night ashore
it's kind of weird what is your idea
little Plotkin really so if I go night
before how do you keep that porn with F
with h5 don't give me that I with a g4 I
mean ok ok I'm going forward for direct
attack here this is not going to work
here I don't think so how to do this
though I can go night f5 but that
doesn't really help that much it's
playable own or grab that rope i think
i'm going to take the rook really not
clear them there's a question do I dream
about chess like certain chess positions
no that really never never happened to
me I mean there was a question like that
unknown on reddit recently and one of
the signs that you are complete chestnut
is supposed to be that you dream about
chess and I really consider myself one
of them one of a chestnut but I don't
dream of our chests never happened
and yeah there's some some artifact in
there in the one day on the broadcast
here near me and the webcam
yeah if the floorboard match was held
with teams defined by first letter of
nice last name could anyone beat the
case no no I don't think so with
Kasparov cup of course not carers now I
think k is some pretty much impossible
to stop them okie dokie this is what is
he doing here rookie one that's a funky
move yeah I guess I have to cancel
yeah the team of case is very strong I
don't really see anybody compete with
that so let's see hmmm to do that maybe
he fall I need to open this pollution
let's go a phone I have to open up the
position while his queen is sitting
sitting there now it's got bishops III
here hmm I didn't see bishops III
maybe this one yeah Mike comer ya could
be the team captain of the case kind of
the court jester for all the grades not
sure that would end up well I think my
camera in the same room with Victor
course I would lead early to the quick
quick demise of mr. comma yeah the seas
were pretty pretty good yeah Carlton
Capablanca caruana sounds pretty strong
well not me and okay what to do now
Bishop's III hmm yeah I probably have to
and then take g5
yeah I don't really think yeah maybe I'm
okay here but I maybe I am actually okay
i will take f5 next and then all kinds
of things are hanging loose hanging and
Queen f2 is is in the mix some rupee a
check as a threat
yes Ruby a check at the end okay let's
do this for Bishop f2
hmm I think it can go rook e8 yeah
there's a question about chess engine
engines do they destroy chest yeah I
don't think we can speak about
destroying chest they definitely do
change the game and have changed the
game already a lot at least on the top
level um but there are also many
advantages you can you get closer to to
the truth and in some positions this is
some certainly interesting from a
scientific point of view even though um
quite often this has very little
practical relevance ok I'm going on
create how many points do I have here
actually two pawns it's not so great
actually Queen g7 hmm
a little Plotkin yeah the thing is I
cannot take a tool really because Queen
have six seams seams crushing okay okay
so let's see if we can win this end game
I Bishop e3 check i blundered Bishop e3
check are very stupid I don't think I
could have won that otherwise don't
believe it
there was a very unnecessary loss okay
anyway yeah as much debate in the in the
chat about top teams with starting
letters top top layers with n
yeah the M team is good more FEMA
rossovich marshal Murat scheme marathi
has a fun fun couple of nutcases
drunkards that's fun and the question
can I even play blind for Chaz yeah of
course I mean every somewhat decent
player can play blindfold it's not very
difficult really but it's something that
I never practiced source um I probably
also can do small blindfold simio like
three or four boards i think i could do
but again nothing that i ever tried to
do so we got them got the same issue the
p team philidor Petrosian pool guy f ski
pillsbury your fields okay I really
didn't put much thought into it
there are any other there's a question
by igniting ideas which player strength
do you consider to be good hmm I not
sure good good deserve as a tough
definition really it's tough too tough
to say what is good there are some some
some differences really there are there
are players around with this visible
reading level that you match around
2,000 that are really really quite
decent they have a good chest culture
they know things about the game and have
a reasonable practical strength but
there are also people on with 2,000
wedding that rely a lot on a certain
part of their game like they're very
good at tactics or very good at openings
and and so on but they have they're not
very well rounded and it's it's it's
really a mixed bag I've nope I know
people with 2,000 rating who are really
very very decent and also some who are
very very much like others one-trick
ponies that i mentioned how serious is
the hedgehog who is the weak point in
the hedgehog there's no particular the
hedgehog is a good opening there is no
particular or setup hedgehog is not not
an opening per se
f6 vu how do i get a meeting attack here
i really want to it feels like I should
get a meeting attack f4 maybe just f4
and work work out the rest later Queen
before know that seems wrong i wonder
if-if five is something he 593 can we do
something here or just normal moose
maybe just go normal moose yeah that's a
huge range of people right there a
variety of people in the 2,000 wrench
they have all kinds of all kinds of
deficits in their game in some cases it
is just nerves I've seen that people who
really know about chance and and can be
really decent for example in analysis if
you look at games with them but they do
stupid things over the board just make
weird practical decisions on they they
forget things that that they should know
because they looked at them a good
memory for example is also very
important skill there are really really
good players who have a terrible memory
so they kind of they look they study in
opening then they sit at the bottom they
they blank out yeah that can also happen
so I really consider people to be very
decent at chess if they are able to yeah
analyze the position and no one little
bit about about the game maybe chess
history things like that um but it can
happen that those people really have big
problems with other areas they cannot
really am yeah memorize their openings
or they have other problems I'm trying
for for the very simple Bishop takes f6
um yeah and he doesn't really do
anything against it so um Bishop F 60 f
five maybe also if I go Bishop f6 yeah
probably he will go Quincy form but I
can take even more stuff now it's
already pretty pretty much in terms of
material taken so look chicks for Luke
g3 maybe oh I didn't even see that this
was hanging how stupid can you be I
absolutely did not see that this this
was hanging poor that makes the whole
thing tricky f4 is also hanging shoot
out for which is seven maybe you can
just take on md5 him my dad had a really
really nice position how did I screw it
up so check here probably he's got
rookie one check and this is actually
made so I have to play one porn so I can
check now on here so I'd wrong or not
probably a draw how can I do this let's
try that's actually interesting here 90
f6 check king of seven bishop age eight
check it's a very funny almost perpetual
okay i can check their king f7 look f8
check king e 7 f-6 check check their
takes f7 and touchdown hempstead winning
i don't know
is that winning or not oh why he can go
there I didn't see that one I only saw
King d6 for some reason not too good I
threatening made actually threatening
mate ok could have taken the bishop
someone says I could have taken the
bishop it's very likely actually but
what about this now I'm [ __ ] stuffy
as well I don't know what's going on yet
it's a very weird position I take you
five next maybe just move the rook ok
let's check have to take it let's go up
so what about those pawns them
it's down to one second here yeah I have
one on time there was a bad game and
there's a question there was a question
if we should add PGN describe a PG any
files in the description of the YouTube
videos I think I think I thought about
this and it it is an idea if you only
upload like one game a week but if you
upload three per day it's a real hassle
to copy it all in there um so I don't
know I'm not a fan I'm not a fan and
that's a question by flynner and in its
opinion cousin is the bus most boring
style of play of any world champion
since most off including the Trojan and
Karpov do I agree hmm well it depends a
little bit how do you defer define
boring i think it's a it's not far um
it's not far from the truth i mean if
you really make a list there and list
all the players in terms of your
excitement factor and the other the
others are probably a little bit more
exciting in comparison however it's also
a little bit i think the sign of the
times nowadays um it's very difficult to
play em to play really exciting chairs
because the the current level of
theoretical preparation
is much much higher and they nowadays
simply avoid a couple of a couple of
opening lines that were very much on
vogue in the past if you look at for
example if you look at tao yeah he had
tons of great attacking games but it was
also due to the fact that back then
people actually played lines in the in
the Sicilian that are pretty much
extinct in our Daisy I like the
classical Sicilian and so on if you play
those lines against calvin let's say he
would also get get attacking games going
because the opponents if they would play
as crappy as Todd's opponents would have
played and then then he also would
attack um um so it's it's simply a bit
more difficult I think nowadays to be m
to be exciting in a way at least if you
compare it to to the times of tau for
example um so I think it's not if you
make this comparison I think Collins
games are relatively speaking not very
fleshy yeah let's do it let's call it
fleshy and I like to study them and I
find it very interesting what he's doing
because it's very far away from what I'm
good at I'm not really good at those
slowish maneuvering yeah and in the end
game I don't know it's a it's very
interesting interesting for me sometimes
to see how he manages to get wins out of
those nothing positions but it's not
very spectacular yeah this is definitely
true I don't like this boring and so on
this kind of category but I think in
terms of excitement it's not not how off
the games are often dry but it's it's
the time it's the the time of them it's
a sign of the times a little bit if you
have openings like the Berlin and so on
yeah it's a bit difficult sometimes to
to play a sparkling chest yeah speaking
about sparkling chest this is not a very
exciting game that I have him
so am I going back to these six now yeah
not create this position yo Carlton
didn't have a great great year but I
think everybody is entitled to we also
feel that it wasn't great because what
we have seen before was simply out of
this world good yeah I mean his his
consistency was really a yeah out of
this world yeah always playing 3000
level performances and so on and this is
something that is impossible to keep
keep up for four key perform for a very
long time
hmm it's going back with this Bishop
that's kind of surprising okay
hmm is am I not rounding up this pawn
down g6 now i'm not quite sure if he
played this right cannot check them and
Roxy for all so it's not really great I
am hmmm this tries to go to d5 hmm okay
coming from the back
mm-hmm but I think I can't do that yeah
he didn't have a really great year for
his for his standards but it's a man i
think it's not a not a bad a bad thing
that he has his up and ups and downs and
i think it would be very helpful for him
to get some good competition so occupy
al what are you doing here can I now try
to get to the pawn down on a three check
hmm okay
it's an annoying move really can I go
for some meeting attack g 5 h 5 h 5 g 5
4 hmm
maybe this one I'm not sure about it
yeah yet some strange moments this year
definitely
trying to keep those pawns I thought you
should take them take them sort of taken
that the Jeep on is there any way to
play for meeting attack here I always
try that if possible maybe this for some
kind of G for business some tricks going
on here if I advance hmm I king f4 maybe
King at four is cool and threatens check
made yep yes f g4 mate and if he takes
the g4 will be made instead of force
mate that would be cool rook f6 maybe
maybe you can go look f6 here in this
position huh only more
I don't have a great reply here funny
enough maybe I should draw here yeah I
don't see you waitin I don't see you win
okay now playing taxi with white so taxi
who is that actually we have the name in
them nope okay let's play the maca gone
off
would there be an on icc stream this
week I'm wondering hmm i'm not quite
sure maybe i will do something tomorrow
I'm trying to remember if i've got
something to do tomorrow evening
the question how much Texas do you get
back I don't know I don't think I get
anything back I rather have to pay stuff
I think
so Bishop d7 am I going for h4 I think I
am I wonder if he can go away five not
sure about it
yeah h5 send annoying resource let's see
what is going to do there's a question
why don't you play the same few openings
every game yeah I'm I want to do them
want to get some variety in so that it's
not the same openings every game there's
a question how much of a sentence they
give in Germany for avoiding Texas
payment hmm it's um it's p I don't know
how hard it is compared to two other
countries I think our our laws there are
like average nothing especially harsh
okay I'm taxi here when g5 the question
is of age six is a move or not going for
the H file or if I should just just take
this Petrosian clamp and be happy about
it I think I'll just take the clamp and
be happy I mean black is in a very bad
situation on the Queen the King side so
I'm just happy with that
yeah for for texture protects fraud we
had a very young and in a very yeah
celebrity case with the manager of the
German football club bayern munich the
president actually and he actually has
just doing jail time now so i think that
was a good a good thing to see that
they're really am there they really am
get heavy heavily punished for avoiding
tax fees nicely played here by taxi
getting the bishop over there to be six
ya know black is is all right yeah if
for wasn't ideal but i didn't see how to
avoid any b5 stuff
some ways clock is not running now it is
running that's weird it's a question
what is my opinion about learning chess
by playing fast time control games I
think blitz chess can support an already
good player with the learning openings
and practicing things like that but I
don't think it is a great general tool
to learn chess they'll certainly have
better ways to do it I have to check
maybe maybe tomorrow or so but you
cannot cannot tell
soon yeah it's it's it's a thing with
those some those streams they're really
i mean if you work chess all day and it
sounds nice and it is nice to do then
actually doing chess all evenings all
the time with with dreams and things
like that it is you really yep you want
to do it and have fun and be
entertaining and if you really don't
feel like doing it it's not such a great
idea sometimes so I rather want to do it
when I really feel like it doing it and
not because I get or not just because I
get many requests for it oh come on why
are you even allowed in that bloody poor
you have a you need people I need to
have they have a need some requirement
for four lakh and this guy is really
lagging far too much
um yeah playing bullet doesn't help your
chairs at all there's a question about
that it doesn't really help at all yeah
good evening to Zurich what do you think
about Vincent Kyle my yeah I've got that
question before the German talent yeah
this guy is kind of disconnected here I
hope it's not me he spent a long time
and I have also got some time detected I
haven't really looked at caemos games
but he's supposed to be really good
Kasparov also said he was a he liked his
games any treatment suggestion for
bullet addiction and no I no not really
just avoided I mean no I mean you can
play it some bullet it's not like it's
yeah but don't overdo it and this sucks
here why what is this this guy's has no
connection or what ten-minute chest is
not so bad there's a question what my
favorite food is hmm okay I think them a
Peking Duck Duck from Beijing this
Chinese food we didn't like duck yeah I
think our best talent in Germany is is
that Vincent come on kid correspondence
chess is good for improving but mostly
nowadays it's about computers yeah he
lost that due to this connection here
okay I'm going to play one more game him
correspondence chess really was a great
tool were like 20 years ago for
analyzing and so on but nowadays if you
don't use computers you will you will
lose all games
is a claim and this is also no fun okay
stop here ask do you think that you can
achieve the GM title um can in terms of
ability yes will it happen no I don't
actively pursue this because just a
matter of spending time if I spend time
on becoming a grandmaster it um it
frankly speaking it just costs money
which I don't have and if you um yeah I
mean I did I have to earn money and I
like to teach so I'm doing teaching it's
totally okay so the guitar is going for
some kind of banco gambit yeah i'm going
to take here this is the typical kind of
position where black is not having
enough compensation but it is messy
enough to be a playable in blitz chess i
guess yeah unfortunately needed two
moves for the bishop but what can you do
get to castle at one point so if i go to
eat too probably he will go now looky
eight is not possible so let's go to you
too
and that's a question if I know the book
give him from by David Bronstein Zurich
1953 we of course everybody um yeah
almost everybody knows that book who
studied chest a little bit seriously and
it's a it's very nice he's drawn
Bronstein did very nice comments on the
games and at years ago um I also looked
through all the games with the
commentary like long ago 25 years or so
it was one of the books that I got when
I started out with chest so I'm going to
take yeah maybe ro kyu won first yet
cheating with computers is pointless but
tell that to the people who do it yeah I
think I should have taken only five that
other the other line was much better
than this snow now black is back in the
game and it shouldn't have happened it
was a really bad position for black
yeah I really don't see the point of
correspondence chess nowadays I don't
see it as a question if I like been fine
gold Feingold terrible no nyah I think
it is quite okay I think it's a very
decent player of course and also okay in
in the commentary wifey just lectures or
so I mean he has his this his brand of
humor that is not everybody's cup of tea
and I understand I I mean I understand
if people say oh the same jokes all over
again and so on and I kind of agree it's
sometimes a bit um yeah you know but
he's some usually giving a good
information about the games and normally
I also agree with his assessment
resistant which is not the case all of
the time they're also chest commentators
that I quite often disagree with that's
a question if I know the book he goes my
such a shock phone how are shown back
hmm hmm to be honest probably not
instead a good move I don't know let's
go I don't have much time I actually
have much time
yeah I was thinking if he takes politics
and next move Queen c-4 would be a big
thread with the discovery at 96 not
quite sure what blacks defenses here
and going Quincy for next no matter what
for the discovery and c8 that should win
actually
Knight b6 and so on I don't see how he
defended yes I was also King edge 8
there's this Knight b6 yeah also I also
was surprised that yeah black resigned
and also was some surprised that Carlton
trained with aronia I mean it just was
interesting to hear surprise me wrong
would I know that they're on good terms
and if you are on good terms why not
train together there are a couple of a
couple of examples of that in chess
history I mean in that 1995 world
championship match Kasparov played
against Allen and his second was kramnik
and it was by the time it was pretty
clear that chronic would at one point
have a match against Kasparov and
happened five years later which
crumbling one so Chris borrow from
actually am yeah um yeah invited his
potential successor to to his training
camp and they have been have been cases
of that in the in the past so this was
the stream a little bit earlier started
but it time went by very very quickly I
hope that you enjoyed it also greetings
to Maximilian on maxim Millie 12
Nakamura would play c8
I have it's also a good move yeah you're
right c8 nice one what if we would have
worked as well okay i hope you enjoyed
the stream i'm not sure if i'm doing
another one later later this week kind
of busy at busy at the moment with many
things ok guys thanks for watching